Générique
...
-Août 2022, Bourges,
dans le Centre-Val de Loire,
la première promotion
de l'école militaire
préparatoire technique,
ou EMPT, fait sa rentrée.
Agés de 16 à 20 ans,
des élèves de première ayant opté
pour un baccalauréat professionnel
ou technologique
vont découvrir le monde militaire.
Objectif :
former de jeunes sous-officiers
adaptés aux besoins
du programme Scorpion,
qui vise à renouveler
et à moderniser
les capacités de combat
de l'Armée de terre,
et aux enjeux numériques
du ministère des Armées.
Quatre filières de lycéens
seront formées à l'installation
et à la gestion
de matériel informatique,
électromécanique et à la maintenance
de véhicules routiers
et aéronautiques.
Répartis en dortoirs
par sections,
les étudiants vont découvrir
la vie en internat
et faire un grand pas
dans leur autonomie.
A travers
ce "Journal de la Défense",
nous intégrerons les bancs
de la première génération de l'EMPT.
Nous découvrirons avec les lycéens
le savoir-faire
et le savoir-être militaire.
Vie en collectivité,
entraînement sportif
et formation au tir,
une immersion
dans l'emploi du temps riche
de ces futurs militaires français.
...
-Hop, hop, attends.
Musique guillerette
...
-Peter, élève de jour cette semaine,
détient beaucoup de responsabilités.
La première consiste
à sortir du lit ses camarades.
-Je me réveille plus tôt
pour réveiller les autres.
C'est mon rôle le matin
de lever la section.
Sinon personne se réveille
et après, on est en retard.
-Il est quelle heure ?
-5h45.
-C'est tous les matins comme ça ?
-Oui.
-La rentrée a eu lieu
il y a quatre mois.
L'école a été inaugurée
par E. Macron.
Depuis,
le protocole du matin est lancé.
Tout le monde effectue
les tâches obligatoires
avant le début des cours.
-Le petit rituel du matin,
c'est le lit.
-Chaque semaine, un élève prend
le commandement de la section.
L'objectif est de responsabiliser
ces futurs sous-officiers.
-OK, je te marque sur le tableau.
On verra ça.
-Ouais, c'est bon.
-Il est 11, OK.
Vas-y, tu peux crier.
Un lycéen crie.
J'ai entendu parler de l'EMPT
par le biais de mes parents.
Mon père m'a orienté sur cette voie.
Après je suis allé au CERFA
de Strasbourg me renseigner.
Ca m'a plu, j'ai fait
mes tests médicaux par la suite.
J'étais apte à m'engager et,
de fil en aiguille,
je suis arrivé ici.
J'ai été surpris
par l'esprit de cohésion
qui s'est direct formé dès le début,
du fait qu'on soit tous
dans le même bateau.
-Prêt, mon adjudant-chef.
-Envoyez.
-On apprend un métier,
ce que je voulais.
Le général, ça me plaisait pas.
Pour moi,
c'était un chemin sans fin.
Quand j'ai su que l'EMPT,
ça pouvait donner
une formation rémunérée,
avec un projet d'avenir sûr,
je me disais
que c'était forcément bénéfique.
Dès qu'on aura notre bac,
on aura un métier.
Alors que dans la vie civile,
on peut bien avoir un bac
et pas forcément avoir
un projet d'avenir.
Tout le monde m'a donné
son téléphone ?
-OUI !
-Oui !
-Attends, tiens.
-T'as pas donné ?
-Non.
-Les élèves ont accès au téléphone
deux fois par jour :
le matin au réveil
et le soir au coucher.
Une distraction en moins
pour ces aspirants soldats
dont l'emploi du temps
est très dense.
C'est une première habitude de prise
pour leur vie d'après.
Les ordinateurs que les adolescents
déballent ne viennent pas
de l'usine du père Noël.
Les élèves de la filière
Systèmes numériques,
réseaux informatiques
et systèmes communicants
font tôt ce matin
leurs débuts dans un exercice
qui les suivra toute leur vie :
le montage d'une tour PC.
-Ici,
vous avez l'emplacement
de ce qu'on voit ici exactement,
du microprocesseur.
Ici, vous avez l'extension
pour une carte mère...
Une carte graphique
extérieure,
le chipset, etc.
D'accord ?
-On va forcément tomber
sur des systèmes numériques.
C'est le nom de la filière.
Savoir comment un PC va marcher,
l'utiliser et le réparer.
On sera amenés à ça,
que ce soit pour les radios,
les transmissions,
tout ce qui va être
aussi optronique,
les systèmes de visées,
de visionnage et autres,
et aussi les PC,
de par ailleurs.
-La partie alimentation,
qui va venir là.
Brouhaha
-On peut les brancher après ?
-Oui, si vous voulez.
-Ton lecteur DVD...
-Cette filière doit former
des techniciens à la préparation,
l'installation
et la maintenance des systèmes
dans le domaine militaire.
Certains d'entre eux rejoindront
les rangs de cybercombattants,
d'autres seront impliqués
dans le développement
du programme Scorpion.
...
-Le programme Scorpion,
c'est l'arrivée
de systèmes d'armes,
des effecteurs de très haut niveau
comme le Jaguar, véhicule blindé
de la cavalerie blindée,
le Griffon,
véhicule de combat d'infanterie,
qui sont interconnectés
avec des systèmes de communication
de haut niveau et qui peuvent
conjuguer leurs effets
en partageant l'information
et les effets
de leur système d'arme.
Le moteur gronde.
Nous avons deux compagnies.
Une compagnie de classe de première
et une compagnie
de classe de terminale.
136 élèves en classe de première
et 72 élèves en classe
de terminale.
Les élèves sont sélectionnés
lors d'une commission de sélection
qui a lieu annuellement
à la moitié du mois de juin,
présidée
par le chef d'établissement,
le proviseur et des cadres
des ressources humaines
de l'Armée de terre.
Cette sélection se fait sur dossier.
On veut des élèves de 16 à 20 ans,
d'un niveau de seconde générale,
technologique ou professionnelle
qui ont l'accord
de passer en première.
-Section, garde-à-vous !
A droite droite.
-Dans toutes les unités
de l'Armée de terre,
il y a des critères
de sélection psychologiques,
des aptitudes médicales,
évidemment,
il y a des critères
de niveau académique,
mais ce qui nous intéresse,
c'est la motivation des élèves.
On veut attirer des jeunes talents,
les consolider
dans leur vocation technique
avant de les aguerrir
au sens militaire.
-Marche !
-J'AI RENCONTRE CE MATIN
DEVANT LA HAIE DE MON CHAMP
-Le projet pédagogique a
3 grands objectifs :
l'édification de l'individu,
former des jeunes épanouis
et ouverts sur le monde...
C'est un accompagnement quotidien,
pas militaire.
Nous formons aussi
des soldats qui auront un niveau
de chef d'équipe à la fin du cursus.
Ils maîtriseront
tous les fondamentaux du combat.
Et nous offrons une formation
technique très haut niveau
avec des moyens uniques en France.
De plus, nos élèves sont envoyés
en stage au sein des régiments
pour parfaire leur métier
dès la première année.
-On va s'attaquer
au circuit de refroidissement.
Vous allez vous placer
sur l'avant du véhicule
et effectuer
différentes vidanges
et pour cela, il va falloir
récupérer les bacs bleus utilisés
dans la salle moteurs.
Vous récupérez quatre bacs bleus,
vous les placez
à l'avant des véhicules.
Brouhaha
-Vas-y, je dicte :
VF 640.
-Attends.
-J 86.
Il répète.
0, en haut. M.
...
B 0.
"14 512".
-Le ministère des Armées continue
sa transition numérique.
La formation s'est adaptée
aux équipements modernes.
La force de l'école est
de faire travailler ses élèves
en groupes restreints
sur du matériel de grande qualité.
Les étudiants
en Maintenance véhicules
et transports routiers
apprennent en conditions réelles.
Les exercices commencent
par une prise de connaissance
des outils avant de passer
à la maintenance.
-On est sur une vidange.
A ne pas confondre.
Vous aviez fait ça ?
-Oui.
-Les lycéens sont évalués
sur leurs connaissances,
leur coopération
et leur capacité à utiliser
et entretenir l'espace de travail.
-Une fois le bac dessous,
je vais ouvrir un peu le bouchon.
-Vas-y.
Elle crie.
Rires
Ca ne goutte plus.
Je peux enlever le bac ?
-A quoi va servir
le circuit de refroidissement ?
-A réguler la température du moteur.
-Oui.
S'il n'y avait pas eu
ce liquide de refroidissement,
qu'est-ce qu'on risquait
comme problématiques ?
-La surchauffe du moteur.
-Ca entraînerait quoi par la suite ?
-Un serrage ou de la fusion.
-Oui, un serrage veut dire
que le piston
ne remonte plus.
-Comme dans la vie professionnelle,
chaque maintenance se termine
par le rangement, le nettoyage
et l'entretien de l'atelier.
Brouhaha
...
Les élèvent poursuivent ensuite
leur journée
autour de cours théoriques
indispensables pour consolider
leurs connaissances techniques.
-Garde-à-vous !
Classe rassemblée.
Effectif théorique, 16.
Effectif présent, 15.
Section, repos.
-Aujourd'hui,
nous allons faire du SolidWorks.
Ca, ça va être le premier solide
qu'on va créer.
Ce cours de construction mécanique
donne une approche
100 % théorique de tous
les éléments de la mécanique :
guidage, rotation, filetage,
les ensembles mécaniques lourds.
Aujourd'hui,
on utilise le logiciel SketchUp
pour qu'ils fassent
les pièces qu'ils démonteront.
C'est pour qu'ils comprennent
pourquoi on fait ça.
Là, c'est une queue d'aronde,
une glissière basique.
Ils comprendront
comment les fabriquer et sauront
comment elles fonctionnent.
On ne va pas en faire
des dessinateurs,
mais on veut
qu'ils comprennent mieux en atelier.
Brouhaha
-Le changement que ça représente ?
Déjà, on est loin de sa famille,
pour certains.
On a un avenir
qui est quand même sûr et certain.
On a une paye,
on est dans le monde actif.
Puis le côté militaire,
c'est pas du tout comme le civil.
Se réveiller le matin,
être au garde-à-vous,
c'est complètement différent
du monde civil.
L'apprentissage,
on est arrivés fin août,
le 25 août,
et on a eu deux semaines
pour apprendre à marcher au pas,
à être au garde-à-vous,
faire le repos règlementaire.
Après ces deux semaines,
on a commencé les cours,
mais pour apprendre tout ce qui est
essentiel à la vie d'un militaire...
-Rotation des poignets,
toujours en courant.
-27, 28, 29, 30.
-Stop !
Assis ! Tout le monde assis.
Debout !
Assis ! Debout !
5 secondes pour aller
toucher le grillage.
Dépêchez-vous !
5, 4,
3, 2, 1.
Revenez, 5 secondes.
Placage au sol, tout le monde !
On rampe, c'est parti.
Rampez ! Rampez !
Baisse-toi. Voilà, on rampe.
Sur le dos !
Allez, on rampe sur le dos.
-Sportivement,
le début était compliqué.
On était beaucoup à être arrivés
et à avoir un niveau de sport...
Moi, en course,
j'étais vraiment pas très forte,
on va dire.
Mais à force de s'entraîner,
franchement,
on s'améliore chaque jour
et même si on arrivait pas
à faire à faire une pompe,
maintenant, on les fait.
Après, le tout,
c'est vraiment de s'entraîner.
Si t'as aucune motivation,
tu n'y arriveras pas,
tout simplement.
-Ouais, OK !
-Ce serait quoi, pour toi,
le parcours idéal ?
-Le parcours idéal ?
Déjà, après les deux ans,
avoir mon bac
et partir à Saint-Maxent,
à l'école des sous-officiers.
Après, aller dans un régiment
qui me plaît et m'épanouir là-bas
et monter en grade
le plus rapidement possible
et dans les meilleures conditions.
...
-A 18h,
et après un après-midi de sport,
c'est le moment
de se remettre au travail.
Ce temps d'étude est dédié
aux devoirs et aux révisions.
La vie en internat ne sonne pas
la fin des devoirs à la maison.
Le programme scolaire est identique
à celui d'un lycée classique.
Il est à assimiler par les élèves
avant la fin de l'année
pour être prêts
pour les épreuves du bac.
-Fin de section de jour.
-Les devoirs terminés,
place à un moment de détente.
Les adolescents ont laissé
leurs stylos
pour des stylets de jeux vidéo,
le temps de se retrouver un peu
hors des cours.
Musique mutine
...
-The winner is...
Brouhaha
-L'extinction des feux est à 22h30,
pour une bonne nuit de sommeil.
...
-On donne le ton
pour le chant de section.
-Petit papa voici la mi-carême
-On marche, pas cadencé,
en direction de la place d'armes.
En avant.
Le départ en chantant.
En avant, marche !
-PETIT PAPA VOICI LA MI-CAREME
-2 !
-CAR TE VOICI DEGUISE EN SOLDAT
-Après les tâches du matin,
élèves et encadrants se retrouvent
sur la place d'armes
pour écouter l'ordre du jour
donné par le capitaine Mathieu,
commandant d'unité.
-Compagnie rassemblée.
A vos ordres, capitaine.
-Merci, monsieur.
Compagnie, à mon commandement,
repos.
Bonjour à tous.
Vous allez bien ?
-OUI, MON CAPITAINE.
-Bien.
Je compte sur vous
pour que vous soyez respectueux,
attentifs, curieux,
et que vous ayez les informations
que vous cherchez.
-Les encadrants,
ce sont le commandant d'unité,
les chefs de section
qui encadrent les élèves
dans les internats,
au quotidien pour gérer le réveil,
la mise en place de la journée,
la fin de soirée, la fin de journée,
et assurer la formation militaire
de nos élèves.
L'encadrement forme nos élèves
à être des soldats.
Pour transmettre ce savoir-être
et ce savoir-faire,
nous procédons
de la façon suivante :
nous les encadrons de façon
purement militaire,
avec un rapport à l'élève
qui correspond presque
à celui d'un rapport
entre un cadre militaire
et un soldat adulte,
mais également, en ayant
dans notre approche de l'élève,
une certaine bienveillance,
un discours adapté à leur jeune âge
pour qu'ils puissent bien comprendre
les messages pédagogiques,
les objectifs qu'on leur fixe.
-C'est bipieds, trois cartouches.
On va pas revenir là-dessus.
Vous écoutez les ordres
que je donne derrière
et ça va bien se passer.
C'est bon ?
-OUI, CHEF !
-Cet apprentissage est
très bénéfique.
Ca permet de leur donner des cadres,
des repères.
Souvent,
ce qu'ils viennent chercher,
c'est des gens qui les structurent,
qui leur donnent des ordres,
des cadres pour avancer
dans leur projet professionnel.
La difficulté des élèves,
c'est qu'on leur demande
d'adopter une attitude plus adulte
que leur âge ne le demande.
Ca veut dire
que nos élèves ont 16 ans,
mais on les considère déjà un peu
comme des adultes de 18-20 ans.
Ca, pour eux, c'est un vrai défi,
de pouvoir répondre aux attentes
d'un encadrement adulte.
Il faut trouver des leviers
pour que les élèves
à la fois travaillent,
s'investissent dans leurs activités,
mais en même temps,
tiennent le coup
et créent une identité collective,
pour qu'ils ne subissent pas
la formation militaire difficile.
C'est vraiment notre défi :
créer cette dynamique collective.
Musique légère
Brouhaha
...
-Ce matin, nous retrouvons
les élèves suivant un bac pro
Maintenance aéronautique,
pour leur premier cours
de réparation
sur un hélicoptère Puma.
-Aujourd'hui,
vous ne ferez pas grand-chose.
Je vais faire, je vais vous montrer
et vous allez voir.
Profitez de cette séance,
parce que ce sera la seule.
Après, vous serez autonomes.
La mise en situation, je lis.
"Le Puma SA 330..."
C'est toujours le même formalisme.
"Numéro XXX".
"...revient d'un vol d'entraînement.
Le pilote inscrit :
"pas de réception VHF 1
et boîte de commandes VHF 2."
Vous savez tous
ce que c'est qu'une VHF 1
et la boîte de commandes VHF 1 ?
-Comme pour la section
Véhicules routiers,
les lycéens travaillent
sur du matériel professionnel,
sur de vrais problèmes techniques
et apprennent
à les résoudre en atelier.
-L'interrupteur batterie,
il est sur "off", OK ?
Vous me dites
"interrupteur sur off".
On ne passe pas sur "on".
Il est sur off,
on ne manipule rien.
-OK.
-Donc si c'est bien fait,
et là, il est bien serti,
on n'a pas à emporter tout le lot.
Je le lève et je l'enlève.
Je vous l'ai fait.
Après, on peut faire
avec le radar météo.
On magouille comme on veut
pour le sortir, OK ?
-Le but est de fournir aux unités
des sous-officiers autonomes
ayant une connaissance
du matériel militaire
dès leur sortie d'école.
Musique calme
...
-Les diapos,
vous pouvez les sortir
et les mettre à côté
pour présenter
la chaîne d'énergie
et d'information.
C'est parti.
-On teste le scanner 3D.
On a une table tournante,
c'est une table
qui fait tourner notre objet,
avec la tête de scan,
ce qui permet...
Il y a des capteurs dedans
et ça envoie plein de fichiers
et ça scanne.
Je reçois tout sur mon ordinateur.
Je peux me transférer les fichiers
et je reçois mes documents.
-Le but,
c'est d'avoir un modèle 3D
des pièces autres
que celles qu'on a déjà imprimées
pour pouvoir les reproduire.
-L'EMPT propose enfin
de suivre un bac STI2D.
Il forme les élèves
dans l'emploi de systèmes
de distribution
et production d'énergie électrique,
ainsi que des experts du numérique
et des réseaux de télécommunication,
une spécialité capitale
pour l'Armée de terre.
Ainsi, l'investissement
dans le matériel est important.
Dès la première année,
les élèves étudient différents
systèmes technologiques de drones,
capteurs ou même des robots.
-On vient de finir
de monter le robot.
Ca nous permet déjà de voir
comment bien le monter
avec les différents servomoteurs.
Ils sont reliés au moteur principal.
Ca nous permet de voir
les branchements
et le fonctionnement d'un robot.
Ca nous permet aussi de pouvoir
le programmer comme on veut.
Après,
dans le manuel, on peut même faire
des véhicules avec ou autre chose.
C'est innovant
par rapport aux autres écoles,
parce que dans les autres,
on n'a pas forcément ce matériel
et pas dans ce genre
d'environnement.
Ca nous permet de travailler à fond
et correctement.
-Là, si t'appuies là...
Ca, c'est quand t'es en mode normal.
Regarde.
-OK, c'est bon.
-La filière STI2D,
Sciences technologiques,
ingénierie et développement durable,
c'est vraiment de la technologie
avec de la physique et des maths.
On manipule beaucoup.
On est sur des TP.
On cherche à savoir
comment un système fonctionne.
Au sein de la filière STI2D,
on va être divisés
en deux parties :
une partie énergie,
ce sera tout ce qui est installation
d'énergie solaire, par exemple.
De panneaux ou de systèmes
pour installer de l'eau,
par exemple.
L'autre partie :
systèmes d'information numériques.
Là, ce sera plus sur déployer
de la transmission,
donc tout ce qui est
systèmes radio, antennes et tout ça.
-Hélicoïdal, c'est...
-J'ai choisi l'EMPT,
car au sein de cette formation,
je vais pouvoir
suivre mon parcours scolaire,
ainsi que mon parcours militaire.
C'est une chance de pouvoir
le commencer à l6 ans.
On est tout de suite
dans le concret du militaire.
On a des activités le week-end,
et en parallèle,
on suit une formation
d'un bac technologique.
...
Donc ce bac,
il est important pour l'armée
qui est de plus en plus innovante
et qui sera confrontée
de plus en plus à de la technologie.
-Repos.
Combien vous êtes ?
-L'école est un équilibre
entre encadrement militaire
et professeurs issus
de l'Education nationale.
L'ambition de l'EMPT
est d'accompagner les lycéens
vers un taux de 100 % de réussite
au baccalauréat.
-On fera en sorte
que vous réussissiez.
Ca m'est important ici
que chacun réussisse.
D'accord ?
-Les cours sont prodigués
par un organisme de formation
qui s'appelle le Greta.
Au sein de cet organisme,
41 personnes,
des personnels contractuels
et vacataires,
dans la 1re phase
de développement de l'école.
-Vous allez souligner
les mots les plus importants.
-"MATIERE".
-"Poésie".
-"Poésie", OK. Et après ?
-"Affirmation".
-Non.
-"Pensez-vous".
-Oui.
Et on va commencer
par le "pensez-vous",
parce qu'il va falloir
éviter certains écueils.
-Une fois qu'ils sont lauréats,
titulaires du bac,
ils deviennent EVSO,
engagés volontaires sous-officiers,
dans l'Armée de terre.
Puis ils vont en école
de spécialisation
approfondir leur métier
au sein des armées.
Pour les titulaires
du bac professionnel aéronautique,
ils ont une mention complémentaire,
une année de plus ici, qui équivaut
à l'école de spécialisation,
et ils complètent
la formation militaire de base
à Saint-Maxent ensuite.
Ils chantent.
-A 16 ans,
la route est encore longue
pour les futurs militaires.
Après ces années de spécialisation,
les jeunes sous-officiers
seront enfin prêts à intégrer
les unités de l'Armée de terre
pour commencer leur carrière.
-Le parcours idéal pour moi,
ce serait de pouvoir intégrer
les régiments des forces spéciales.
Bien sûr.
Pour ça, je suis pas très difficile.
Tant que j'ai un poste
dans un régiment de l'ALAT,
ce sera très bien pour moi.
-C'est vraiment une expérience
qui restera gravée à vie
dans nos mémoires,
pour tous les élèves de l'EMPT.
L'une des meilleures
qui puissent exister.
Je conseille très fortement l'EMPT
pour tous les jeunes qui veulent
commencer en tant que sous-officier.
C'est vraiment incroyable.
-L'EMPT représente un enjeu majeur
au sein de l'Armée de terre,
en termes de recrutement
et fidélisation,
puisque nous voulons fournir
50 % de sous-officiers techniciens
de l'Armée de terre
en recrutement direct.
-Ce que l'on souhaite
aux futurs élèves,
c'est d'être
des sous-officiers exemplaires
dans les missions
qu'ils auront en tant que soldats,
qu'ils sachent encadrer,
qu'ils sachent assurer
les missions opérationnelles,
mais également qu'ils soient
des techniciens exemplaires,
professionnels,
capables de réparer des véhicules,
du matériel à la technique complexe.
C'est bien ça
que je souhaite à l'EMPT.
-Repos.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...